salut nouveau casse-tête sur la chaîne
ça fait bien longtemps qu'on avait pas
eu de casse-tête mais vous souvenez je
vous avais dit je vais pas faire autant
de casse-tête qu'avant parce que à force
ça va vous lasser et on retrouve les
mêmes mécaniques maintenant j'en ferai
quand j'en ai des rares des exceptionnel
dans les mains et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui j'avais avec moi le samedi à
et juste avant je vous le dis placement
de copain merci beaucoup à Hubert et aux
équipes de l'insolite casse-tête donc
selon moi la meilleure boîte de
casse-tête en France si vous en cherchez
je vous mettrais un lien dans la
description ils me l'ont prêté une
longue confié ils l'ont eu aux enchères
pour 1500 euros il y en a que 400 dans
le monde et ils me l'ont confié pour que
pour que je le réserve quoi si j'avais
envie c'est un casse-tête qui a été créé
par Jessy born et les casse-têtes de
Jesse bond sont sont très appréciées
dans le milieu des des casse-têteurs on
va on va l'attaquer c'est lourd hein
c'est lourd c'est beau c'est incroyable
c'est parti alors tu connais on va
commencer par la phase de découvert
d'exploration on a un truc vachement
lourd dedans
il y a clairement quelque chose ça bouge
ça ou pas non ça bouge pas ici
petite bande avec un comme un bijou
qu'on peut bouger comme ça là c'est une
sorte de cylindre mais qui serait pas un
cylindre parce que il est à 6 côtés donc
ça s'appelle un hexagone qui a envie de
bouger mais qui bouge pas en dessous
j'ai déjà repéré qu'il y avait ça mais
ça a pas l'air de bouger mais il y a des
petits symboles et il y a l'arrière de
ce truc là ça ça bouge pas non plus ici
là ça devient intéressant ça il y a
plein de symboles autour c'est relié à
ça qui relie à ça où il y a plein de
symboles autour et regarder l'ensemble
on peut le bouger comme ça
plus ou moins facilement j'ai
l'impression donc là il y a forcément un
bail avec ça et c'est parti là sans
amovibles quand même les unes des autres
là vous le voyez ça on peut le bouger
indépendamment de ça qui bouge pas
tellement celui-là ça veut dire que
quand on tourne cette partie là elle
bouge pas du tout ça ça me donne pas
trop l'impression de pouvoir bouger
quand je parle de ça je parle de ces
crochets là comme qui doivent être
tenues ici et ici les côtés là j'ai un
peu le jeu là non là oui et sur les deux
côtés en même temps et en fait tout ce
qui est en renfoncement a l'air de
pouvoir bouger par contre on peut le
bouger ou pas ok les symboles on peut
aussi les bouger qu'est-ce qu'on a
dessus on a comme des petites pyramides
est-ce que je la retrouve ailleurs ces
petites pyramides malheureusement pas du
tout
là on voit un bitonio dans un trou là et
un chaque fois pas là non plus
oh
je ne sais pas ce que je fais là ça fait
un clic vous l'avez entendu et
maintenant je peux tirer ça incroyable
stylé de ouf donc tout va peut-être
s'ouvrir au fur et à mesure c'est
incroyable ça là il y a plein de
symboles ça c'est quoi c'est un bouton
ou on tire là on peut le dire
[Musique]
[Rires]
tout l'intérêt de pas faire beaucoup de
casse-tête et d'attendre d'en avoir des
fous c'est que même moi j'ai des
émotions incroyables ça s'applique très
clairement ça peut appuyer sur un papier
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ce papier il
est incroyable il est incroyable
tu t'en fous Loïc
tu veux voir c'était ça c'était comme ça
du coup j'ai pu ouvrir là et quand j'ai
ouvert le bloc qui était là à
l'ouverture et la pêche il s'est rangé
là
il avait un truc de planter à
l'intérieur je l'ai enlevé et ça fait
fou ça s'est ouvert direct
et il y a un petit bout de papier que je
suis en train de découvrir il a froid le
bout de papier la mère de Loïc
on entendra rien
avec ça j'arrive à appuyer sur le petit
téton
elle était toute
[Musique]
le jaguar est à abattre j'ai rangé cette
note
ok parce que alors regarde pendant que
toi tu faisais un travail de traduction
de haute voltige si je peux me permettre
ça m'a permis d'appuyer là pendant que
toi tu lisais
et de me dire tiens dis donc je peux
ouvrir cette nouvelle cache mais ça je
leur ai montré t'inquiète pas par contre
quand j'ouvre l'une ça ferme l'autre
attention
je trouve rien vraiment rien du tout
mais ça c'est ce qu'on croit mais ici il
y a un emplacement pour mettre quelque
chose peut-être un truc aimanté qui est
quelque chose je sais pas et là je me
suis dit grâce à ta traduction de haute
qualité on pourrait accéder à des
indices de haute qualité
c'est pas facile fluent alors pour tous
ceux qui veulent récupérer le James
Stone ils doivent moi j'aimerais la
récupérer par exemple
tu dois tuer le jaguar tu es d'abord le
Jaguar et la mobylette cherra
si je l'enlève
je suis bloqué à cause du pétouu
saisissoir et donc là
alors que je vous dise là je peux faire
tourner là je peux pas lui l'enfoncer
par contre de ce côté là je peux
clairement enfoncer la lance jusqu'au
bout mais sur un tout petit bout de
l'Exode sur un sixième sur cette partie
là il y a aussi cette partie là qui est
fixe peut-être que
c'est la même chose de l'autre côté par
contre il y avait des dessins en dessous
[Musique]
en gros là je me dis
ces choses qu'on a ouvert toujours dans
le même sens est-ce qu'on a pas la
possibilité de les ouvrir dans un autre
sens qu'on l'a glissé ici mais peut-être
que d'une manière ou d'une autre
[Musique]
là vous les voyez là là c'est un peu des
jaguars quand même qu'on a sur la gauche
[Musique]
j'ai cru qu'il tenait en dessous et que
genre j'avais découvert un aimant de ouf
et tout allez le mentaliste
[Musique]
j'arrive pas en démordre que ces choses
là qui glissent là celui-là vers la
droite ou celui-là vers la gauche je
pense qu'il faut trouver la manière de
faire en sorte qu'il glisse dans l'autre
sens là c'est un peu plus dans la rue ah
oui mais là c'est ah oui c'est moi qui
fait ce truc j'ai l'impression
d'entendre des mécanismes secrets c'est
moi qui fait ça
ça le seul endroit où je vois que ça
pourrait aller c'est c'est le truc dont
j'ai enlevé ça tout à l'heure vous
souvenez c'était à l'intérieur d'un
cercle et je crois que je peux le faire
revenir
OK et si je lâche bon et repart c'est
pas illogique là il y a le cercle de
tout à l'heure je me dis bon je mets la
pièce imbécile le petit Picot en face du
trou voilà comme ça ça va l'aider à
tenir
[Musique]
je l'insérer dans la tirelire
est-ce que ça unlock quelque chose
est-ce que ça du coup je peux peut-être
le mettre dans ce sens là non ça sert à
rien changer ici ça fait apparaître
quelque chose
pas du tout parce que c'est redescendu
c'est quand ah franchement elle était
bien ma théorie c'est-à-dire que on a un
cercle on sait pas où le mettre depuis
tout à l'heure
et ici on a de quoi mettre un cercle ça
donne quand même franchement envie ah
ouais ce que ça
il est où ah non mais moi j'ai pété le
casse-tête là pour l'instant donc
je l'ai pas pété mais en fait
c'est
bon je sais où j'en suis moi
ça fait des petites baffes comme ça
quand tu racontes n'importe quoi bon ça
me ça m'en dit pas plus voilà je fais un
truc comme ça et je le
trouve quand c'est bloqué à mi-chemin
peut-être que tu peux faire un truc je
souffre déjà pas mal avec ce casse-tête
se casse-tête
[Rires]
pourquoi pourquoi je peux là
j'ai aucune idée de ce qui vient de se
passer en gros comme j'ai eu un clic en
le poussant là j'ai continué à le
pousser et j'ai cherché à tirer de ce
côté en faisant le cercle complet et je
pense que j'ai passé un tête au bout
d'un cercle complet en fait peut-être
tout simplement mais là waouh c'est très
bizarre ce qu'il y a dedans ok j'ai un
scorpion
[Musique]
ou peut-être j'ai tué le Jaguar et là
c'est peut-être le poison du Scorpion
peut-être que ça ça me permet ah ça ça
me permet de bouger ça ah oui c'est
carrément une molette comme ça waouh
Loïc je vais appeler Loïc larchéologue
Loïc l'archéologue mon champion comment
il va
là ça disait non
ok le poison du Scorpion attends mais il
y a des trucs de symbolique là il y a
pyramide
attends mais attends il y a des symboles
là pyramide carte si tu es des jouets
perdus pyramide carte si tu es des
jouets perdus c'était dans spectacle de
Dora l'exploratrice
[Rires]
je peux faire un peu tourner les
serviettes quoi mais genre comme des
petites girouettes et après ça dit que
la spire la spire là là
pour doubler le pouvoir du coffre de la
mer c'est le coffre Dany dalgo ou quoi
ouais mais c'est un peu le rappeur non
rappeur ratons l'aspirateur
tu fais quoi
franchement j'attends un clic déjà ça je
l'ai ouvert
j'avoue c'est un peu cheater comment
j'ai réussi à l'ouvrir mais ça ça m'a
clairement servi à rien depuis le départ
ah oh mais oui
le centre du Scorpion
ceci cela
et là
je double le Power et là je fais
[Musique]
et puis attention les enfants de 1
tu veux prendre la suite un peu non
j'aille boire un petit coup tu me fais
un café alors ça va
monteur capteur une poutine
le cercle est pas si grand que ça donc
il y a pas 3 milliards de possibilités
tu vois toi tu vois ce que ça fait 1
milliards
là si je lâche tout titre là je suis
vraiment en train de de forcer forcer
comme si j'enroulé un élastique tu vois
ce que je veux dire bah non mais comme
toi tu m'as dit il faut doubler le
pouvoir du Power moi je le fais pas avec
tout le truc là mais je le fais quand
même avec la petite roue je vais
réfléchir ok si on trouve la bonne
combinaison alors ça j'avoue je l'ai pas
moi j'ai une patience éternelle non je
me dis que avec lui si je mets la bonne
combinaison en haut peut-être qu'en
refermant et qu'en refaisant un cercle
je pourrais peut-être ouvrir l'autre
côté parce que lui je l'ai ouvert que
dans un sens pas dans l'autre ça c'est
été ma théorie au tout début de la vidéo
un extrait maintenant ces choses qu'on a
ouvert toujours dans le même sens est-ce
qu'on n'a pas la possibilité de les
ouvrir dans un autre sens qu'on l'a
glissé ici mais peut-être que ça ça
s'ouvrirait dans les deux sens et ce fut
le cas on dirait une marque de quelque
chose c'est clair mais un truc plutôt
constipé prenez un trajet fulca
ah ouais alors attends alors peut-être
que là avec ces symboles là il parle
d'un espèce de cercle bizarre mais
j'arrive pas à faire ce que c'est en
tout cas il y a une pyramide dans le
temps donc s'il y a une pyramide ah non
peut-être la pyramide doit être à côté
de
quelque chose ah c'est pas clair c'est
pas clair cette histoire oui pour un
moment donné
[Musique]
j'ai même pas essayé de le faire avec ma
basse qui était les trois pyramides
c'est ça que j'avais au départ parce que
j'ai quand même une pyramide sur le truc
au début
il y a dedans ce qui vient de se passer
là il y a dedans j'ai commencé à pouvoir
l'ouvrir et là maintenant il est bloqué
ah peut-être parce que ça ça bloque non
attends j'ai un truc dedans
un rouage une capsule un
autre truc ah ouais c'est qu'il y a un
truc qui bloque là oh merde je
crois qu'il y a un truc qui est pété
derrière là en fait là je sais pas si
vous allez percevoir ce truc là il
devrait pas être là et il bloque
l'ouverture de la porte ouais vous
entendez c'est pas normal ok oui oui
pas sûr que ce soit normal je pense
qu'il y a eu un
là je crois sincèrement regarder on voit
les traces de colle c'est quelque chose
qui était en collé et qui aurait jamais
dû être décollé
j'ai réussi à ouvrir à ouvrir celui que
je voulais ouvrir contre sens
là il y a un petit cercle ici regardez
je sais pas mais regarde là vous le
voyez ici il y a une roue et il y a un
petit trou dans la roue donc moi je
pense que si je mets la lance dans le
trou et que je tourne un peu il peut se
passer regarde ça bouge là
tu as peur moi je m'y attendais je m'y
attendais regarde et là boum parce qu'on
a déjà vécu ce moment avec ça c'est pas
du tout passé comme ça tu veux la
remettre
[Musique]
là il y a un petit cercle ici regardez
ce petit cercle là on pourrait mettre ça
dedans et faire
rien
[Musique]
vu
voilà oui bon c'était moins glorieux au
moins il est incroyablement chouette en
plus la boîte est très belle et elle est
fatale
parce que c'est il n'est pas à nous
bravo à vous ça fait plaisir pour un
retour rondement mené il faut tout
remettre dans son état initial
[Musique]
mais moi j'aime bien ne pas tout
comprendre je trouve ça garde un petit
peu le mystère mais tu sais ce qu'il y a
encore plus mystérieux que ce casse-tête
le fait que vous soyez toujours pas venu
me voir en spectacle peut-être et je
suis en tournée actuellement avec mon
spectacle l'archétype de mentalisme du
Boré de sciences dans toute la France
jusqu'au mois de juin enfin les villes
qui restent et surtout le 22 novembre à
la salle Pleyel 2023 c'est une bonne
idée ce serait le genre de mon
anniversaire il y aura un nouveau numéro
un nouveau il y aura une nouvelle mise
en scène il y aura des écrans ça va être
aussi incroyable vous avez tout ça dans
la description prenez soin de vous à
très bientôt
santé Ciao